neo4j an acid compliant graph database
that can handle the extremely complex
relational data of the modern world it
was created in 2007 by Emil ifram is
written in Java and pioneered the
property graph model traditional
relational databases use a tabular model
but joining normalized tables together
is not how real humans think about
relationships naturally we think about
connections between entities like Bob
asked a question on stack Overflow then
Alice and Chad downvoted it so Bob gave
up on his dream of programming a graph
can model this data the same way you
might visualize it on a whiteboard nodes
represent entities edges represent
relationships between entities and
properties are key value pairs that
store data on these objects under the
hood neo4j is a true native graph
database that applies this model all the
way down to the storage level queries
are written in a declarative language
called Cipher that resembles SQL except
nodes are surrounded by parentheses then
connect to other nodes with arrows via
relationships and brackets today neo4j
is used in applications like
recommendation engines social media
platforms and knowledge graphs for
artificial intelligence and just to name
a few to get started it can be
self-hosted with Docker but the easiest
approach is to sign up for Aura which
provides a free fully managed database
in the cloud from there we can build the
next Twitter by making queries with
Cipher use create followed by
parentheses to create a new entity or
node this node has a label of user that
can be used to group similar nodes
together inside the braces we can add
key value pairs to represent the data on
that node now a user might want to
follow another user which can be
represented with a relationship inside
of brackets then notice how the arrow
points to another node with a label of
user and that's all it takes to create
relational data no foreign keys or join
tables required although we can add
constraints to the schema such as the
one here that will ensure every username
is unique in addition we can define
local variables in this query then
return them from the statement to get
the data back as the result and what's
especially awesome is that we can
visualize it as an interactive graph or
even as a table now to continue building
Twitter we can connect multiple tweet
nodes to a user we also need a query
that will return all the tweets from all
the users that are being followed this
can be easily represented with nodes and
relationships but we can also filter
this query with a where Clause to only
return tweets that were posted recently
in addition we can match on string
patterns and regular expressions or
filter on complex patterns based on the
graph itself like only return tweets
from users that have not been muted so
not only is it intuitive for developers
but it also allows patterns in your data
to emerge naturally which is a huge
Advantage when it comes to data analysis
and machine learning this has been neo4j
in 100 seconds hit the like button for
more short videos like this thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one